- [Announcer] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(lively music)
- So these are the
Berkeley Graduate Lectures,
the Hitchcock Lectures
and as you heard yesterday
when Carol gave her first
talk on how telomeres cause
age-related disease, there's
a great story in discovery
that can be serendipitous
and so today, Carol,
I'll introduce her shortly,
will give us a story
that's been retitled The Anatomy
of a Scientific Discovery.
She's gonna tell you really
much more about the process
of how scientists discover
things that are later deemed
to have high impact as we all would agree
from the 2009 Nobel Prize
in Physiology or Medicine.
So Carol is a professor and director
of molecular biology and
genetics at Johns Hopkins
but she started as a California native.
She was born and raised
here for the most part
and she went to UC Santa Barbara
for her undergraduate
degree and then came here
to UC Berkeley for her PhD.
And from there, went to Cold
Spring Harbor Laboratory
as faculty and in '97
then to Johns Hopkins.
But it's from Cold Spring
Harbor from the early 90s
that I know Carol where I had the pleasure
of joining her research group.
And there are many things that you'll hear
that are really important
features in a scientist
who's committed to doing
discovery basic research.
And Carol exemplifies
really those features
and I think in part, the
MCB graduate program here
and Carol, to me, have the
important starting point
as she'll talk about of
curiosity-driven research
and hard work.
But I say that it takes much more
than just curiosity and hard
work because it also takes
the patience to let the question unfold,
to let the real question that
you should be answering unfold
as opposed to the question
you started asking.
And also it takes the insight to recognize
when the question you should
be asking comes along.
And I'll just quote in
fact from the 1945 winner
of the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or Medicine,
Sir Alexander Fleming whose comment was,
one sometimes finds what
one is not looking for.
In describing his discovery of penicillin
which he discovered accidentally.
He's a bacteriologist, he loved to watch
and understand how bacteria grew
and he had stacks and stacks of plates
from his curiosity his hard
work and he put them aside
and one day, he happened
to notice in the corner
of one of these plates
a giant colony of mold.
And this is not what he
set out to do to grow mold
but he noticed something about this mold
and it was this insight
that led him to penicillin.
He noticed that this particular mold
wasn't just competing with the bacteria
for space on the plate, it was
actually killing the bacteria
that surrounded it on the plate.
And from there, he recognized,
that insight that hmm,
this could be a new question to study
as opposed to the question
that I started this experiment
with in the first place.
And I really, I've
learned a lot from Carol
and I've learned a lot from
this process of learning
not just to be curious
but to have more patience
and to let the questions change and evolve
and take you to what you
weren't sure you were asking
in the first place.
So thanks Carol and
welcome back to Berkeley.
(attendees applauding)
- Well, thank you very much
for that perfect introduction
for what I'm hoping to tell you today.
So yesterday, we talked a
little bit about the science
of telomeres and telomerase.
And today, I thought that I
would take off a little bit
and use telomerase and
the discovery of telomeres
as a way of telling a story
about exactly that about
how serendipity and chance play a role
in the progress of science.
So once again, as we were
discussing yesterday,
we'll be discussing telomeres.
So for those of you that
weren't here yesterday,
I'll just go back over this.
Within the nucleus of a
cell, you have chromosomes
and the genes are all along
the length of the chromosomes
and the telomeres are these end parts
that protect the ends
and maintain the length.
And so we'll be talking a little bit
about some of the
discoveries along the path
to understanding the role of telomeres
in a number of different organisms.
So if you think about
scientific discovery,
in hindsight it may
seem that the discovery
is a fairly linear process.
So telomeres were first
recognized as important components
in the 1940s and then the
telomere sequence is identified
and then it was clear
that there was a role
of telomere elongation in
telomere length maintenance.
Telomerase was predicted.
Telomerase was then discovered.
We then understood the connection
of telomeres and cancer
and then telomeres and
disease and then in 2009,
a Nobel Prize for the
discovery of telomerase.
So it may seem like this is a
linear process when in fact,
the process is really much
more complicated than that.
So what I'll be doing is
explaining how in reality
the process is very messy
involving serendipity,
personal interactions, insight, hindsight
and various other approaches.
So I don't expect you to
understand all of this yet.
We'll kind of go through
it and work our way through
but there are two points
that I want to make
at the beginning.
The first of all is that this timeline
is not an accurate linear timeline.
You'll see that the 1980s are greatly
overly represented here.
There was a lot of a particular
progress that went on
in the 80s and the early 90s.
So this isn't meant to be an
accurate linear representation
of time but also,
I'm taking a fair amount
of artistic license here.
So this is not meant to be any
kind of a definitive history
and I apologize in advance for anyone
who's important discovery
I might not mention.
This is really meant
to be more metaphorical
about how the process
of discovery unfolds.
So this isn't meant to be
taken as a definitive history
by any means.
But there are gonna be some themes
that I'm going to bring
out during this talk.
And the first is the curiosity
is a driver of science.
Discoveries tend to happen in batches.
That's in part because
people talk to each other
but it's important that
discoveries happen in batches
because replication is really essential
to establish a new discovery
as something fundamentally new.
Fields collide and inform each other.
So you may be working on one area
and then start working in another area
and it's the juxtaposition of those fields
where a lot of new things
can usually be found.
And scientific discovery
is not like engineering.
Changing direction or
objectives can be a good thing.
Very much like what you
just heard from Cathy.
Being able to be distracted
by something that may be
the question that you really should ask.
And then finally, another quote,
this one from Louis Pasteur,
that chance favors the prepared mind.
So we'll be working through
some of these themes
as we go through as an example
of a scientific discovery,
some of the discoveries about telomerase.
So the telomeres were
first functionally defined
as units that protect chromosome ends
in the late 1930s, early
1940s by H.J. Muller
working in drosophila
and Barbara McClintock
working in maize showing that
there were functional units
that had to protect chromosome ends.
But then that initial recognition
of these functional units
had to wait a number of years
before we could really understand anything
about the mechanism of
what these functional units
actually do.
So it was in 1972 that there was a paper
that was published by Jim Watson,
one of the co-discoverers
of the structure of DNA,
and what he defined is what's called
as the end replication problem.
The problem with replicating the end
of any kind of a linear DNA molecule.
And so if you have such
a linear DNA molecule,
it turns out that what
was known in the 1970s
was the mechanism by which
this replication occurs
is that you start copying this chromosome
from an internal location,
and when you then copy to the very end
of the linear molecule,
it turns out that there's a small region
because of the biochemical mechanism
by which these are made,
there's a small region at the
very end of the chromosome
which isn't copied.
And as you go through this
process and continually copy
many chromosomes, you then
expect that chromosomes
would shorten progressively
from their ends.
So this was a theoretical paper
that was published by Jim Watson.
And around the same time, it turns out
that there was a paper,
also a theoretical paper
published by Alexey Olovnikov
in the Journal of Theoretical Biology.
Although he did not use the
term telomere in this paper,
he noticed that there may be a problem
with copying the ends of molecules
and he used this term marginotomy
being the margins of the chromosomes
instead of using the word telomere.
And because of that
different usage of words,
his publications weren't well known
to the telomere community
until a number of years later.
However, Olovnikov did show
that there was this
theoretical problem of copying
the ends of chromosomes and
he had the important insight
to link that to a paper
that had been published
in the 1960s by Len
Hayflick which suggested
that if you take primary human
cells and put them in culture
that they have a limited
life span in culture.
So this limited life span of human cells
was termed cellular senescence.
So back in the 70s, these
two ideas were linked
but as you'll see, we
weren't able to follow up
on what that meant until
a number of years later.
So the first molecular
characterization of telomeres
and this is one of the
themes that will bring out
is that as soon as you
identify actual components
and the molecular mechanisms,
it's easier to understand function.
So the first molecular characterization
came from the identification
of the telomere DNA sequence
in Tetrahymena, this
single-celled organism
that has 40,000 chromosomes.
And what's shown here is
a nice electron micrograph
of this particular molecule
which is important from Tetrahymena
which was a 21 kilobase molecule
that has telomeres at both ends.
And so Elizabeth Blackburn and Joe Gall
were very curious about what
was the actual DNA sequence
that was at the ends of those chromosomes.
And they published this paper in 1978,
and what they showed is
that there were many copies
of this very simple
sequence on both of the ends
of these molecules.
And so that then defined
the telomere repeat sequence
for the first time in any organism
as these tandem repeats
of simple sequences.
So this paper was in 1978,
shortly thereafter, just
three years thereafter,
there was another paper
again from ciliated protozoa,
in this case, Oxytricha
which looks a little bit
like its cousin Tetrahymena
although they are actually
quite distantly related.
And what this group showed was
that there was a very similar
tandemly repeated DNA sequence on the ends
of the chromosomes in four other ciliates.
So in this case, this
Oxytricha telomere sequence
was tandem repeats of the sequence T4, G4.
So there's T4, G4, T4, G4.
And then they showed at the very end,
there's an extension on
one of these DNA strands
relative to the other and it turns out
that this was a very important
functional characterization
of the ends of the chromosomes.
So the end replication
problem should predict
that telomeres shorten
every time cells divide
because you can't completely copy
to the end of the chromosome.
And so in understanding this
as a theoretical problem,
there is sort of a mindset as to okay,
how are you going to overcome
this telomere shortening?
However, telomere shortening was not seen
when you were growing these
Tetrahymena cells in culture.
So why was it that telomeres
aren't apparently shortening
as cells are growing in culture?
In fact, it was found
very shortly thereafter,
the telomeres would actually get longer
in some single-celled organisms
as you grew them in culture
and this was very counterintuitive.
So unexpectedly, there was
this telomere elongation
and this was a paper
from another single-celled
organism, trypanosomes.
And if you look on this
the Southern blot here,
there's a band that does not
change size as these cells
are growing for increasing
numbers of divisions in culture,
but then, this telomeric band
here, as you grow these cells,
it actually got longer
which is the opposite
of what one had been thinking about
with this end replication problem.
So this didn't make a lot of sense.
However, when you do this
same experiment in Tetrahymena
where the telomeres were first identified,
again, it was seen that the
telomeres actually got longer.
So here, our cells grown
for increasing numbers
of cell divisions and this telomeric band,
you can see in increasing
in length as these cells
are grown continuously in culture.
So this is another example
of discoveries happening
in batches so we really
believe that this is the case
that there is this telomere elongation
but yet we don't know why that is.
So in the early years of
the telomere research,
we were really gathering
pieces of the puzzle together.
They really didn't fit,
but by gathering up all these
various different pieces
then trying to interpret
what may be occurring.
So the telomeres were shown
to be functional units
and then the end replication
problem was proposed
and that was linked to
cellular senescence.
The telomere sequence was also identified
which allowed an understanding
of what's going on
at the molecular level and
then one was able to see
this telomere addition.
So that was sort of the early
stages of trying to understand
what was going on with telomeres in cells.
The next important
functional characterization
came from this experiment that was done
by Liz Blackburn and Jack Szostak
where they were able to show
that Tetrahymena telomeres
would function as telomeres in yeast.
So here is a circular plasmid
which was very familiar
to people that were studying yeast
and when you take that circular plasmid
and open it up and add
Tetrahymena telomeres
onto the ends of these chromosomes,
these actually, the Tetrahymena telomeres
functioned as telomeres in yeast
and as I'll be saying in a few minutes,
they were actually elongated in the yeast.
But this paper was published here in 1982.
And in '83 and in '84, again,
similar kinds of findings
were also made independently
by other groups.
So here's one paper which
has a kind of unusual title
that doesn't really tell you
what's happening in the paper
but what they did in this
paper also published in Nature
was they showed that there
must be GT-rich sequences
which are present on the
ends of chromosomes in yeast
and they showed that there was addition
of GT-rich sequences onto
the Tetrahymena telomeres.
Also in 1984, there
was a paper that showed
that when you take telomeres in yeast,
if you take now, in this
case, Oxytricha telomeres
and put them into yeast, that
those Oxytricha telomeres
would function as telomeres in yeast
and that they were elongated,
so again, here's an example
of discoveries happening
in batches and reinforcing one another.
So this general concept
that telomeres would work
in a variety of different organisms
was clearly very well established.
And then later, in '84, the
Szostak and Blackburn lab
went on and identified the actual sequence
which was added on to these
Tetrahymena telomeres in yeast.
And from this paper, they
proposed that there maybe
some kind of an activity,
telomere transferase-like activity
that would extend this GT-rich strand
of the yeast telomeres.
In the exact same journal
where this was published
in Nature in 1984,
the next paper in the journal
was a paper by a group
that was also proposing a way
that you could elongate telomeres.
How is it that telomeres
are shown to be elongated
and why would you have
these sequences added on
to the Tetrahymena telomeres?
And I'm not gonna take you
through this complicated model
but basically, what this group proposed
was that there was a
recombination mechanism
by which telomeres could be added
as opposed to de novo addition mechanism.
So I'll just show you the cartoon here,
a recombination mechanism.
You can imagine that if
you have a particularly
long telomere and then a short telomere
is that you can actually
copy this one strand
from the short telomere can
invade the longer strand
and you get net elongation
of the short telomere
and then repair synthesis.
But the main point here
is that you start off
with a long telomere and a short telomere
and you end up with two long telomeres
by a mechanism that was
a well-known mechanism
in the DNA repair field.
In contrast, what had been
proposed for the de novo addition
is simply adding on to
this three prime end
sequences in this direction
and then filling out
and getting met elongation
by this mechanism.
So the same set of data
led two different groups
to propose two very different models.
So understanding that telomere
addition may be occurring,
one group proposed a
recombination based model
and another group proposed
that there would be de novo elongation.
So it wasn't necessarily
clear how this would come out
in terms of the importance
to telomere replication.
And as you will see,
we'll be talking a lot
about de novo elongation
although later on,
recombination also will
turn out to be important
in addition.
So both of these pathways
will turn out to be important.
So when I came to Berkeley to
work with Elizabeth Blackburn,
I was then charged with
trying to understand
is there any evidence for something
which would add new telomeres
onto the ends of chromosomes?
So to test one of those two models
which was the de novo elongation model.
And so what we did was
to take again Tetrahymena
which has a source of many telomeres
and we were hoping would have a source
of many of the components
which were necessary
for making telomeres and to grind them up
and put them into a test tube
with the right sort of reagents
and the reagents would be
something which would mimic
natural telomere end and the precursors
for the telomeric sequence
which is necessary to be made
and what we found was that
this enzyme telomerase
would extend the primer
by adding sequences
of the telomeric repeats.
And that is what is shown here,
the elongation of the telomeres.
So this was just one year later
after the initial discovery
that the telomeres were
added on to the Tetrahymena
telomeres in yeast.
Then by asking the question
how is it that you can actually
have an enzyme add something
that is not templated
onto the ends of chromosomes?
We propose that perhaps,
there's a essential nucleic acid involved
that is an RNA component.
And we identified this small RNA
which contains the complement
of the telomeric repeats
as part of the RNA and showed that the way
that the telomeres are
elongated is by copying
this template within the telomerase.
So those discoveries
happen in a relatively
short period of time.
So after we understood
about the telomere addition
and the de novo elongation,
this predicted the telomerase.
Telomerase was discovered
and the RNA component
was identified just a
few years thereafter.
So we're basically collecting up
the different kinds of
components of the machinery
that's necessary for
maintaining telomeres.
So another question that
we didn't really know
very much about that was
going on about the same time
was trying to understand from
the standpoint of the telomere
what's actually bound
to the telomere itself?
The telomerase would be the enzyme
which would make this longer
but what is normally here
along the telomere.
And so a number of groups were interested
in identifying what
the components might be
that would make up the telomere itself.
And in a series of papers
that were happening
in the middle 80s, again,
the team era binding proteins
were first characterized by
Dan Gottschling and Tom Cech,
again, in ciliated protozoa.
These organisms that have
many tens of thousands
of telomeres.
Again, going to the
source of where telomeres
are most plentiful.
So they found that there was evidence
for a specific telomere complex.
And then Dan Gottschling and Ginger Zakian
were able to identify
the specific proteins
that were bound in that
complex and then finally
actually cloning to know
the individual subunits
of this telomeric complex
occurred in the early 90s.
So the discovery of telomerase
then was around the same time
as the discover of these
telomere binding proteins
identifying the individual components.
So at this point, what we knew about
was that there were these
telomere binding proteins
and most of the work had been done
in either yeast or ciliates.
Either Tetrahymena or Oxytricha.
And it still wasn't necessarily clear
to the wider community of biologists
that what we knew about telomeres
in these single-celled organisms
really would be informative
of anything that might happen
in humans or in other mammals,
that is what relevance
did this actually have
to human disease?
Now, certainly, from the
standpoint of a biologist,
we knew that something
that was very fundamental
for all cells very
likely would be conserved
throughout many different organisms.
Although it wasn't necessarily clear
to the scientific community at that time.
So the first hint of what
was actually going on
in human cells came in the middle 80s.
From this paper that was
published by Howard Cooke's lab
and what they found was
that there was a region
on the X and the Y chromosomes
which was very close
to the human telomere.
So this is a cartoon of the
human X and Y chromosomes
and of course, most of these chromosomes,
most of the DNA on these chromosomes
is different from each other but turns out
that there's a region
which is called a pseudoautosomal region
which has sequences that are present
on both the X and the Y chromosomes
and Howard Cooke was trying to understand
this pseudoautosomal region
and what he came across
was that when he probed for these probes
that the bands that he saw
were very heterogeneous
and this looks very much like
this heterogeneous sized band
that was seen for telomeres
in both Tetrahymena
and in yeast cells.
So here was a hint that the evidence
that we had for what
telomeres would look like
in these single-celled eukaryotes
may actually play a role
in human telomeres.
And they went on then to do
really the definitive
experiment at the time
to show something that
something really is telomeric.
What you do is you you take
and you treat with a nucleus
and this is an enzyme which
will chew away from the end
and this heterogeneous band here then,
if you chew away with it with a nuclease
for increasing amounts of
time, it decreases in size.
So this suggests that it
really is the natural end
of the chromosome.
So this was in 1985 and we didn't yet know
the sequence of the actual telomere.
Okay, so these bands, they are identifying
because they're looking with sequences
that are very near the telomere.
So they still didn't know
what the actual telomeric sequence was
of the human sequence.
It wasn't until 1988 when the Moyzis group
was interested in looking
at repetitive DNA sequences
from humans and they came
across this repetitive sequence,
T2, A, G3 and they were able to show
that that repetitive sequence,
when you hybridize that
to human chromosomes
and you may be able to
see here on the ends
these faint yellow dots on
these red human chromosomes.
They were able to show
that this repeated sequence
is actually present, not
only on the human chromosomes
but also on many other
vertebrate chromosomes
in mouse and a variety of other organisms.
So this now definitively identified
the human telomeric sequence
and this was really an enabling discovery
because it allowed testing of models
for what's happening with human telomeres.
Again, the discovery in one
lab leads to rapid discoveries
in other labs.
So the human telomeres
and the entire sequence
of the human telomere was then cloned
by two different groups.
Again, in back-to-back papers in Nature
and these groups use
the exact same approach
as had been identified for
cloning the yeast telomere
by Blackburn and Szostak,
that is to take and put
human DNA into yeast cells
and showed that human DNA
actually functions as a telomere.
And they used nuclease sensitivity to show
that that cloned human
DNA actually was telomeric
and this is once again another example
of discoveries happening in batches.
And this is important not just because
a lot of things are happening
around the same time
but because by these very similar findings
coming from different groups
from different angles,
it really established in a
very short period of time
the importance of these sequences.
So we had been focusing on telomerase
and the telomerase components,
the telomere binding proteins
and then with the identification
of the human telomere
sequence that then allowed us
and others to go on and test models
that have been around
for a number of years.
And specifically, the model
that we were able to test
was this question about
telomere shortening
in primary human cells as
they divide in culture.
As I said, it had been
proposed in the 1970s
that the progressive telomere shortening
in human cells may play a
role in cellular senescence.
And so I was fortunate to collaborate
to be able to ask this question
very shortly after the identification
of the human telomeric sequence,
we were able to show that if
you actually take human cells
and put them in culture
as Hayflick had done
and showed that these cells divide
for a certain number of times in culture
and then stop dividing
and we were able to use
the human telomeric DNA
probe and show that indeed
the telomeres shortened progressively
as these cells are dividing in culture.
Not only does this happen with cells
that are dividing and culture in humans
but it also actually happens
in human cells with age.
So this is an example of
the average telomere length
taken from a gel like I just showed you
compared to the age of the individual
and that there's a progressive
telomere shortening
with age in these human white blood cells.
And now, having recently
discovered telomerase
and understanding that
telomerase is necessary
to add sequences on to
the ends of chromosomes,
what we initially thought
was well these cells
perhaps don't have telomerase
and so they're shortening progressively
in the absence of telomerase.
So that's what we thought then
that there was no telomerase
in these somatic cells.
But now, what we think is happening
is that although there
may be telomerase activity
in those cells, the telomerase
activity is limiting
and the cell division can
outpace the elongation
that's occurring by telomerase.
So within the lifetime
of these individuals,
there's so much cell division going on
in the blood cell compartment
that the division gets ahead
of the ability of telomerase
to elongate those telomeres
and that's why you see
this telomere shortening.
So as I mentioned, it was
proposed a while before
that cellular senescence may have some,
that telomere length may have some role
with cellular senescence and
so this is really the point
that ideas aren't always
connected in a linear fashion,
that past work that we
didn't really understand
maybe how it fit in to the story
can then become relevant
later on and in this case,
it became relevant because we knew
the human telomere sequence,
and we needed to know
what that sequence was
in order to do the experiment
to ask about the telomere shortening.
So indeed, knowing this
human telomere sequence
then led us to understand
about the cellular senescence
even though this had
previously been published
a number of years before.
So along with understanding the telomeres
and cellular senescence,
the other thing that was quite
enabling for understanding
the human telomere
sequence was understanding
about telomeres and cancer.
And the same year that we were looking
at cellular senescence, Titia de Lange
with Harold Varmus we're
looking in both cancer cells
at different tissues.
And what's shown here is the fact
that there is tissue specific differences
in telomere length within people.
So they're looking at telomeres
that are are quite long in one person,
comparing the sperm telomere length
to the blood telomere length.
So these are two different tissues
and two very different telomere lengths.
Another example here, sperm versus blood,
much longer telomeres in this setting.
And then over here what they found
was that if you compare
normal tissue to tumor tissue,
that there was significantly
shorter telomeres
in the tumors.
Again, normal and tumor, so
there were shorter telomeres
in tumor cells than in normal cells.
And we now can understand
this because that tumor cell
has gone through more
rounds of cell division
than otherwise would
have due to some change,
genetic change that allows it to divide
and that more rounds of cell division then
allows this telomere shortening.
So as I had mentioned before,
discoveries happen in batches
so at that very same year,
there was another paper
which was also published
showing in this case,
the normal is shown, normal telomeres here
and tumor telomeres from the same sample.
Normal and tumor, normal and tumor
so there's a telomere
shortening in cancer cells.
So discoveries happen in batches
and independent replication
is very important
for verification of fundamental ideas.
So in addition to understanding
the telomere length
in tumor cells, it was interesting to know
what is the role of telomerase
activity in tumor cells.
And so we were interested
in the role of telomerase
and when telomerase may
be present in tumor cells
and so this particular
paper, telomere shortening
associated with chromosome instability
is arrested in immortal cells
which express telomerase activity
was the first example of telomerase
being activated in cancer cells
but I do wanna have a
little disclaimer here
that even though I'm an
author on this paper,
I wanted to just apologize
because one of the things
when I was doing my PhD
thesis here at Berkeley
was that my colleague Jasper
Rine told me many times
that you should not
write cells which express
but cells that express.
So I just wanna take that as a disclaimer
and I will never make that mistake again.
So this was a paper that
showed that telomerase
becomes activated in cancer
cells and then two years later,
a definitive paper also showing
that in most human cancer cells,
you have telomerase activity
in order for those cells
to go on and continue dividing.
So this is a getting back
to some of the issues
that are raised yesterday in the talk
and that telomerase is required for cells
that divide many times.
So the fact that you see activation
of telomerase in cancer cells,
this one particular cell
undergoes to genetic change
that has to divide many times
and this cancer cell has to
solve the telomere problem
and one of the ways it does that
is by activating telomerase.
After fundamental discoveries are made
in a particular field,
it turns out that there's a can be
a lot of activity in the field.
And so what I've shown you
so far is many of the papers
throughout the 80s which we're
leading up to establishing
all of the different components,
the telomere binding proteins,
the telomere sequence,
the telomerase activity to
understand what might be going on
with telomeres.
And so if you look at the
total number of publications
with a word telomerase in it,
across here there were
a number of publications
but it looks like it's zero
and then at this point,
once we have enough enabling discoveries,
the number of publications
really just skyrocketed
and people started investigating
more about different kinds of cancer cells
and how much telomerase is there
and what's going on with
the telomere length.
So this is really a common
phenomenon in many fields
once you reach a critical
mass of understanding
of the individual components.
So we had understood the telomere sequence
led to understanding senescence
and it also led to understanding the role
of telomeres in cancer.
It was very important though to understand
the different components
if we were gonna understand
the role of telomeres in human disease
to understand those components that are on
the ends of chromosomes.
And the first identification
of the proteins
that bind to the ends of
chromosomes in human cells
came from these two papers
from the de Lange lab.
Identifying this protein TRF1
or telomere repeat binding factor and TRF2
and you can show in this nice
set of chromosomes over here,
now, we're looking at the actual proteins
that are bound to the chromosome ends
that these proteins are
binding to the very ends
of these human telomeres.
And so the identification of TRF1 and TRF2
then led to the identification
of what we now call
the shelterin complex.
So TRF1 binds along the
length of the telomeric DNA
as does TRF2.
So these were the first two
components that were identified
and we now know of this
complex of proteins
that's needed to protect
the human chromosome ends
and also plays a role in elongation
of the telomeres with telomerase.
So we still, at that
point, although we knew
many of the different components,
we didn't know what the
makeup of telomerase was.
We knew it had an RNA component
that provided the template
but the catalytic component of
telomerase remained elusive.
And it was again the ciliated protozoa
that came to the rescue.
So Joachim Lingner and Tom
Cech's lab first identified
the catalytic component of telomerase
from another ciliate called Euplotes
and then working together
with Vicky Lundblad
showed that there was a very similar
kind of an enzyme in yeast.
And this is just one
figure from their paper
where they were able to show
that the important catalytic
regions of this enzyme
that they had identified
actually was similar to
a reverse transcriptase,
to this example, the HIV RT
suggesting that this telomerase
reverse transcriptase was
the catalytic component
of telomerase and this was
quite an important discovery
because now that the field had their hands
on an actual molecule, you can then go
and do experiments to test hypotheses.
And one of the first
experiments that was done
after the identification
of the TERT enzyme
and knowing what the human
TERT was was to express
that component inside human cells.
And as I had shown you that if you look
at these cells that have been grown
for a long time in culture,
you have relatively short telomeres
as shown in these four lanes here
but as soon as you put back the telomerase
and so you add more telomerase to cells,
what you find is that the
telomeres are elongated
and in this case, this would increase
the number of cell
divisions that those cells
would go through and culture
showing that the telomeres
actually do limit
the number of times cells
can grow and culture.
And this was quite an enabling
discovery because now,
in a number of different laboratories
working in a variety of
different cell types,
people could grow cells
and be able to study them
for a longer period of time in culture.
And so today, many different
human primary cells
can be grown for a long term in culture
if you simply put this
telomerase back into the cells,
you can now grow those cells with it
because they're not know longer limited
by the short telomeres.
So in terms of practical
applications for scientists,
this makes it easier to understand
many different cell types.
So the identification of
the human telomeric sequence
directly enabled the
understanding of shelterin
and telomerase allowed the
discovery of the TERT component
which then allowed many
additional discoveries to be made.
So the final question that all,
I'll just leave you with here.
I won't go through many
of the other discoveries
but the question of about
what actually happens
without telomerase?
And this was the subject
of my talk yesterday
but this is just an
example of if you have mice
that lacked telomerase
in the first generation,
you cross those mice, you
get second-generation mice
that have shorter telomeres,
you breed those second generation mice,
you get third-generation
mice with shorter telomeres,
et cetera, for increasing
number of generations
that this progressive
telomere shortening in mice
actually leads to a number
of different complications.
And what happens at the cellular level
is that with each generation,
the telomeres get shorter
and those short telomeres then trigger
either cell death or cell senescence.
And this was shown by a
number of different groups.
However, it turns out that
some cells can actually
escape this cellular senescence
although most of the time what happens
is the cells undergo cellular senescence.
The short telomeres also play another role
and this was also something that was shown
a number of years before and that is
that they can sometimes
escape and they can undergo
a recombination pathway
that allows them to escape senescence.
And so this is just a
figure from this paper
of Vicky Lundblad and Liz Blackburn
indicating that there is a bypass pathway
that if you don't have
elongation by telomerase,
the telomeres can be
elongated by recombination
and this is harking back
to what was proposed
about 10 years earlier.
And that is the recombination telomeres.
So the discovery of telomerase led
to being able to ask the question
about what are the
consequences of short telomeres
and remarkably, recombination
is one of those consequences
and this is something that again,
the process doesn't
necessarily work linearly.
Recombination was proposed
a number of years before.
The cellular senescence
is one of the consequence of telomeres.
Initiation, the DNA damage response
and cell death was another consequence.
So the overall synthesis of this
is that defining the molecular components
together with understanding
the consequences
of short telomeres allowed the discovery
of human disease mechanism.
So many of these components
that we've been building up
over the years then led
to the understanding
of the human genetic disease
dyskeratosis congenita.
So understanding the telomeres RNA
and understanding the
consequences of short telomeres
led to knowing that this disease
is actually a disease of short telomeres
which then several years later made clear
that there are really a
collection of different effects
of short telomeres often
called the telomere syndrome.
Understanding these consequences puts new
understanding about
telomere length regulation
and these experiments are
really still the focus
of many different laboratories today.
So as I was concluding yesterday,
discovery is not a linear process
and new discoveries sometimes
come from unlikely places.
Tetrahymena and Oxytricha.
So some of the themes that we've
been discussing here today.
Curiosity is a driver of discovery.
Discoveries happen in batches.
People talk to each other.
And replication is essential
to establish new discoveries.
Fields collide and inform each other.
Scientific discovery is
not like engineering.
You have to be ready to change direction
and follow what's most interesting.
And chance favors the prepared mind.
And so with that, I'll just
leave you with one final slide
and that is where was
telomerase actually discovered?
Wendell M. Stanley Hall at UC Berkeley.
Many of you may or may not recognize this.
There's a nice vintage car
sitting outside on the circle.
And my final point today is
that you can't go home again.
This is what happened to Stanley Hall.
So here's the remnants
of how it used to look
and now there is a new
beautiful building in its place.
So all, thank you for your attention.
(attendees applauding)
- [Attendee] Hi, thank you
very much for your great talks.
I read a biography last
year about Henrietta Lacks
who was the donor for HeLa cells.
Sorry, I'm a chemist, not a biologist
but it's my understanding that those cells
were somehow unique in being
able to avoid senescence
and we're used widely in
molecular biology research
and until recently
and I'm wondering if there's
any understanding now
of were those cells somehow
able to use one of these
mechanisms to avoid senescence.
- Yes, so the HeLa cells are a cell type
that is derived from cancer.
So in the case of Henrietta Lacks,
her tumors that were put into culture
and this happened for many
other different cell types
and as I had shown what happens
is that telomeres do get short
but then telomerase becomes
activated in cancer cells.
So that's a widely common phenomenon.
In the case of the HeLa cells,
it happened that they were found
to be very useful by people
and so they'd been used in a number
of different laboratories
as our other cell line.
So there weren't anything
unique about those cells
having activated telomerase
but they were a cell type
that was a very easy to grow in culture
because they had been derived from a tumor
and so they were a very useful resource
for understanding human cells
and so they were widely
distributed to many researchers
to understand human biology.
- [Attendee] Thank you
so much for your lecture.
My question is you said
the study was done on rats.
So the synergist effect of
the cells getting short,
you talked about that but
how do you make them grow?
I mean as far as diet and activity,
how did you make the
cells grow in the rats?
- Do you mean the tumors or?
- [Attendee] No, healthy,
we healthy cells, right?
That are long.
- So the experiment that I
showed where you can take
normal human cells and normally,
the telomeres are shortening progressively
and then if you put back
this enzyme telomerase,
you can make the telomeres be elongated
and those cells will now grow
for many, many more divisions
because you no longer
have the short telomeres
that limit the growth of those cells.
So those are normal cells that
now have what we would call
an extended lifespan or
have become immortal.
- [Attendee] Immortal.
- Mm-hm.
- [Attendee] I have two
interrelated questions.
Number one, in the cancer cell,
you mentioned telomere
length is shortened.
So why does cancer cell
not enter into senescence?
Why does it keep on dividing?
And second thing you
mentioned in the cancer cell,
telomerase activity is very high.
So why does telomerase does
not make the telomere length
go back to the normal length?
- So you you hit on something exactly
this kind of counterintuitive.
I did tell you that cancer cells
tend to have shorter telomeres
and I showed you some evidence
from some historical papers.
Cancer cells have shorter telomeres
but cancer cells also
have telomerase activity.
And so it's that telomerase activity
that maintains the telomere
length in the cancer cells.
So that's why they don't
undergo senescence.
So they started off with long telomeres,
they went through a number
of rounds of cell divisions
where the telomeres were shortening
and then they got telomerase activity by,
we're not sure exactly what mechanism,
perhaps a mutation.
Now they have to embrace activity
and now they're maintaining
the telomere length.
Why they don't go back
up to the original level?
We don't know the answer to that.
That's a very good question.
However, we do know that
these are cancer cells
and so they don't have many of the normal
regulatory mechanisms that
normal cells would have.
So we have actually done the experiment
of shortening the telomeres
in a completely normal organism in mice
and then when you put telomerase back,
you do end up going back
to that normal set point
because it's the normal
regulation of those enzymes
but it doesn't often
happen in the cancer cells
and that's because there's
probably disrupted cells.
But you're right, it's counterintuitive.
- [Attendee] I have one more question.
What do you think if a cell
has entered in the senescence,
can that cell can be reverted
back to the active state
or this cell will remain again
forever for the senescence?
- That is a good question.
Once this an individual
cell has entered senescence,
it is thought that you cannot
drive it out of senescence
and these are experiments that
we're done before telomerase.
If you can put in agents which will cause
the cell to undergo DNA replication.
In the experiments that I'm showing you
where you take a culture of cells
and all of those cells are
heading towards senescence,
now you put telomerase into the cells,
some of the cells are
still actively dividing.
They haven't yet gotten to
that final senescence point.
And so when you put the telomerase in,
now you rescue those
cells that are dividing
and the telomeres get long and those cells
don't enter senescence.
But I did not show you
that if it's actually
already that one cell is in senescence
that you can get out of that.
Probably not.
- [Attendee] Thank you.
- [Attendee] Does the same biology apply
in the plant kingdom?
And I'm wondering about
some trees that can last,
live for hundreds of years
and whether it has a similar
relation to telomerase
or telomeres.
- Yes, one of the things that's
really very nice to study
something so fundamental
as chromosome ends
is that the mechanisms are
conserved across all organisms.
That is all organisms that
have linear chromosomes.
And so yes, this this
mechanism does occur in plants.
There are a number of plant studies
that have been done out there.
The telomerase is known,
the telomere length is known
but just as in mammalian cells,
the telomeres don't determine
the maximum lifespan
of organisms.
That is the maximum
life span of human being
about 100, 120 years old,
that is not determined by telomeres
and we can show that in mice
and a number of other organisms.
There are probably many different things
that determine the maximum lifespan.
So similarly in plants, the telomeres
aren't gonna determine
how long that organism
is gonna live but the
telomeres are carrying out
the exact same function,
the telomerase is the same
and these mechanisms are conserved.
- [Attendee] And another thing,
in the complex which includes TERT,
is there any supposition that
was introduced evolutionarily
by a retrovirus?
- I'm not sure what complex
you're talking about.
- [Attendee] The C-E-R-T part of the.
- Oh, the TERT.
- [Attendee] TERT.
- Oh, yes, yes, the telomerase, yes.
- [Attendee] I have dyslexia.
- So telomerase, the telomerase enzyme
copies RNA that's part
of the enzyme into DNA
on the ends of the chromosomes.
And so it has hallmarks
of what is now found
also in reverse transcriptases.
But if you actually look
back evolutionarily,
they're both related to
enzymes that copied RNA
and so they diverged later on so you may,
there are some supposition that actually,
the telomerase diverged before,
the reverse transcriptases diverged
but they are related
with the common ancestor.
- [Attendee] Thank you for the talk.
In your multiple generations
of your knockout mice,
I didn't see comparative survival curves
and it appears that you can
have multiple generations
without telomerase and
still have viable progeny.
- Yes, you can in both in mice,
for the first three generations
when the telomeres are shortening,
in the absence of telomerase,
there was no consequence
of the telomere shortening
as long as your telomeres are long.
Once the telomeres get to
be shorter, in our case,
in the third, fourth, fifth
generations as their shortening,
the short telomeres themselves
then trigger apoptosis or
senescence which causes diseases.
So you can live without telomerase
as long as your telomeres
are long but then,
once the telomeres get short
and the same thing is found
in human families that don't
have enough telomerase.
In the early generations,
there's no consequence
and it's not until the later generations.
- [Attendee] Thanks.
- [Attendee] Thank you for your talk.
Yesterday, you had mentioned
that there is no clinical
research or evidence
that shows products that
are currently out there
being marketed to help lengthen telomeres.
So can you address whether,
I'm assuming that there is
research currently going on
to try to find either plant
or botanicals or something
that will help to lengthen telomeres.
And I understand that there
may not be clinical research
study data but that there's
many hundreds of thousands
of anecdotal data about things like
traditional Chinese medicinal
herbs that can help to,
you know, help bone marrow
or make gray hair black again
like He Shou Wu.
So can you address that?
- I'm not an expert in any
of those sorts of medicines.
I certainly know that
there is a lot of interest
in both sides of looking at telomeres
in finding ways to lengthen telomeres
in the setting of bone marrow failure
and pulmonary fibrosis, that
if we had some mechanism
whereby you could lengthen the
telomeres and maintain them,
that would be really an
outstanding treatment
from people that are
dying from these diseases.
So there's a lot of
interest in looking at that
and there has also been on the other side
some interest in looking
at telomerase inhibitors
as approaches to cancer.
But now that we know a little bit more
about the normal consequences
of having less telomerase,
we need to just step back
and think a little bit
about how long you would
want to inhibit telomerase
before you may have other effects.
So one needs to have a little
bit more of a nuanced approach
but these are definitely areas
that people are actively
trying to understand
as we understand the disease,
understanding treatments for the disease.
My colleagues at Hopkins
see patients every day
that are dying from these diseases
and there's no treatment
so we were very interested
in pursuing that.
Thank you.
(attendees applauding)
(lively music)